jedinak mir schon star wars oder wie ich
bin dein vater
hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video biglia selber meiner freizeit sehr
gern tiefer 17 und deswegen habe ich mir
gedacht ich mache heute mal 417 video
klingt logisch oder in der tat deswegen
befinden wir uns jetzt schon in das ist
ultimate team
ihr seht schon oben linken sind meine
münzen meine bilanzen auch meine fifa
preuß und zwar habe ich mir jetzt
einfach mal 2200 fifa points gekauft
dass ihr heute ist kein video in dem ich
jetzt alle gegen irgendwen anders fifa
spiele sondern ich werde einfach ein
paar packs ziehen und darauf reagieren
ob ich gute sachen kriege oder nicht
wenn ihr allerdings mal sehen wollt wie
ich zocke und das nicht mal so ein
zusammenschnitt mache wie ich online
spiele und ich raste da sehr häufig aus
hass auf jeden fall leichter und bei 40
eigen mache ich dann vielleicht damit
ich sehe dass es viele leute wollen es
gibt heute jumbo premium setzt die lauf
in fünf stunden 47 ab das eigentlich
wäre jetzt einfach mal meine fifa points
dafür benutzten hier so ein paar packs
zu ziehen ich hatte noch nie etwas gutes
in hexen das fest jetzt ein spieler vom
handy haben nun wahrscheinlich bobadilla
oder wir haben nur kacke in den sets
alter was soll das duo marcel flm ich
glaube das auch nicht so gut das nächste
patch öffnet sich meine damen und herren
ich möchte einfach nur mal
und strothmann das tat ich habe ich noch
drin und cruz
das einzige was ich davon immer behalte
sind die verträge für meine spieler halt
es tut mir leid falls dieses video
eventuell nicht auf den geschmack trifft
allerdings meint ein paar leute luca
spiel der fifa 17 oder macht mal wieder
ein bisschen gaming deswegen hab ich
gedacht ich mach hitech opening april di
maria komm gib mir glück kommen es muss
doch jetzt mal irgendwas kraft drin sein
komplize einmal die lange mit rund
einmal die klagen wenn man mein leben
wahrscheinlich kriege ich nastasi den
ich vorhin schon hatte ich habe barclays
team also aus der premier league
deswegen bringen diese ganzen deutschen
spieler einfach gar nicht das einzige
was behalten die verträge ich hoffe
übrigens läuft alles weil das ist das
erste mal dass ich wirklich mit ps4 auf
elgato aufnehme
auch komm geh doch mal graben warum
immer nur diese leute mit sitz am ende
nastase basis schalter was kommt als
nächstes mal in habe ich noch gezogen
das ist ein rechter verteidiger dem pack
ich auf jeden fall noch in mein team
rein der pastor nämlich sehr gut rein
das hier ist jetzt das letzte jumbo
premium gold etwas beziehen danach
werden wir glaube ich mal umsteigen auf
die anderen gold packs also mal schauen
kommt bitte gib mir irgendetwas bleiben
nein ja cool grimaldi habe ich jemals
glück das ist echt so beschissen ich
habe schon so viele packs gezogen als
fifa sind sie doch gerade raus kam habe
ich das auch gemacht dass ich mir für 10
euro oder so ein paar points gekauft
habe aber nie glück alter den kann ich
vielleicht noch ein bisschen gut
verkaufen weil der 90 ps hat als stürmer
aber elf mann was soll da ist die ganzen
verträge wieder meinen verein reihen
aber ähnlich fakt ist einfach nur noch
ab dass ich hab nie glück er gut ich
meine wenn man so sieht es ist mega
selten dass man etwas gutes lied aber
ich sehe man bei den ganzen fifa kanälen
die kaufen sich genauso viel power point
sondern dann kriegen die aber gute
sachen nicht ähnlich bmi um gold digga
von manuel rieke 77 ist das beste
produkt in diesem pack ich ziehe jetzt
noch ein jumbo premium gold sitcom bitte
da muss doch jetzt irgendwas kraft drin
sein bitte enttäuscht bin ich lass doch
mal flammen kommen okay jetzt kommt
albert glatt ist das jedinak wie schon
star wars oder wie ich bin dein vater
wie wirst du eigentlich braun schnell
verkaufen 9400 münzen ist das in einem
krassen team oder so ich habe keine
krasse ahnung falls es irgendeinen von
fifa 17 oder der sich damit auskennt
sieht oder so ich weiß nur das ist
irgendwie wie fifa 16 dieses team oft
egal wo die spieler glaube ich blau
waren oder so und es gibt noch so in
form spieler die sind jede woche quasi
neu und das waren sie die besten spieler
der woche und die sind dann halt in
schwarz und die anderen
attribute mehr und sind halt mega teuer
und irgendwie ist dieser jeden tag wohl
auch so einer weil sonst würde ich hier
nicht stehen schnell verkaufen 9400
münzen sofort kaufpreis hunderttausend
alter wollte mich verarschen okay dann
sag ich immer zum transfer dann machen
wir jetzt vielleicht doch noch etwas
gutes gezogen hier marco rollt kommen du
bist wirklich mein allerletztes jumbo
premium gold kommt ja irgendwelche
flammen irgendwas krasses comagic cool
ich hasse dich vielfach nur wenige
minuten später
leute ich bin so süchtig ich habe mir
noch mal 1050 fifa points gekauft hatte
eigentlich solche leute die so viel geld
in spieler investieren aber ich muss
dieses video irgendwie interessant
gestalten doch irgend etwas vernünftiges
ziehen weg mich jetzt bitte nicht fifa
ohne spaß ich habe extra noch mal zehn
euro in die hand genommen kommen da
müssen doch mal irgendwann flammen und
lang und alles und move alle bist du
mann sagt das übrigens die ganze zeit
mit von wegen da müssen hinten flaggen
runterkommen und so weil wenn wirklich
krasse spieler am start sind dann kommen
dahin also die flyer unter der spieler
leute hinter dem dem set her und so was
alles an deck geht noch es müssen einmal
krasse flammen kommen es muss einmal in
der krassesten sei nirgendwo
österreicher oder war dann auto.de
gartner irgend etwas krasses muss noch
mal kommen nur schwachsinn ihren
mannheimer glück hatte scheiße
ich habe noch 450 fifa points das heißt
ich kaufe mir noch eines von diesen
jumbo premium gold sets und danach noch
ein normales schon wieder keine flammen
und werden verbrannt ski jedoch schief
wendiger nur scheiße nur scheiße es gibt
bei fifa sommers heißt chemistry style
also da kann man beispielsweise dem
stürmer etwas gebe und er hat dann plus
attribute beim schießen und physisch
oder irgendwie so ich hatte jetzt in
diesem dschungel premium gold etwas mit
300 fans gekostet hat einen basic style
das ist das schlechteste was es gibt vor
allem dann auch noch im hamburger in dem
set acom was will ich mit haben bekommt
er die letzten fifa points investiere
ich jetzt in ein normales premium gold
wenn da jetzt laden runter kommt es
alles in ordnung aber
für mich dieses spiel eigentlich
verarschen